(ding)
- I have absolutely no idea what Arak is.
- To be honest, when I first heard
the name of it, I thought of the country.
(Middle Eastern music)
I'm told that this is
like a major, iconic drink
in a lot of Middle Eastern countries.
- [Man] This is clear.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Man] I don't like that,
it reminds me of moonshine.
- 50% alcohol!
- That's a really little bottle
to contain 27 drinks.
- Is that, that's a lot.
- So, for Caitlin, someone
who doesn't drink often,
this is gonna suck.
- Smells like black licorice.
- We go one-third Arak
and then two-thirds water.
- Like, I don't get the whole water thing.
Like, can you not just drink it straight?
Whoa, it's like a weird --
- Is that milk?
- You know dishwashing water?
- I don't like that, it makes me feel
like there's something going on in there.
- All right, cheers, bottoms up.
- [Caitlin] Oh, it's fine!
- [Man] Oh, no,
it's quite nice!
- Ugh, it gets you.
- The first initial taste is
like really (bleep) strong
and then it's great.
- It kind of reminds me
of like an ouzo or grappa.
- I would say that's straight up Galliano.
- It's definitely an
I'm-getting-drunk drink.
- You can definitely
taste the alcohol in this,
but it's not overpowering,
which doesn't really make sense,
'cause there's about 50 drinks in that.
- That totally makes sense now
why we had to add water.
- This can be dangerous.
- Doesn't even feel alcoholic.
It feels like cordial that's
meant to taste like licorice.
- A long, never-ending shot of
I want to go home now please.
- I came in thinking I'll be drinking
the most ghastly drink
ever, but it was great!
- I don't think that I'd be bringing
this out every weekend, not at all.
- I'm feelin' a buzz.
- This is the prime drink you can
sneak into a music festival.
- Yeah, just say it's like fancy water.
- This is probably up there with
one of the strongest drinks I've ever had.
- This right here is everything I want
in a drink: it's easy to go down,
it's alcoholic as hell,
and it's refreshing.
Great job, guys, love it.
- So they drink this in the Middle East.
- Yes.
- In countries like Iraq.
- Yup.
(laughter)
- I tricked him.
I love this.
- [Man in white] It's great.
- [Man in blue] I would
straight up love this.